yeah hello welcome to another Friday
edition of play the people starring Mike
hover and back from vacation
Jonathan great rock back I'm so excited
to be here this is the show where Mike
comer takes you on I assume we're doing
one minute one minute bullet knows no
delay no increment and rate it and this
is actually a very special edition
because we just doubled since we started
streaming in December the amount of
people following us on Leach s so this
is our thousand followers spectacular
Mike comer thank you everybody for all
the big fellows and very exciting stuff
Mike for president yeah that's a good
way to start it I don't know these
political ambitions but I see you rune
Thorson I'm following you guys in the
YouTube chat I don't see anyone in the
twitch chat but I will be following you
guys there so well yeah go ahead and
send in your challenges there should be
a way we can put a link here in the the
things you can find us to challenge us
some people have figured it out I guess
we have really cool sound effects today
- nope not distracting at all yep good
to see a rune Thorson oh I didn't want
to trade I don't like it I don't like
puns let's go a good start here come on
now that's no that's I think it's love
that tub that's already been decided I
get rid of this Bishop get my knight
here
I still have chances that's still yeah
that was big mistake for him to play
that move because now check and I take
it and life is good all right just take
it right I'm so fast all right one of
this time to come down speed here I can
tell I don't know why he thinks he's
winning I'm winning now as long as I
don't blow it
I think speeds gonna be the most
important thing all right so let's just
play a little faster and don't get them
free pawns huh
analysis chest is requesting the Kings
gambit and if you've been taking
requests or how you feel about the Kings
gambit yeah good to see you analysis
chess good to see you gifs and is there
anyone actually watching on twitch I
don't see any messages here I don't know
if that's a meeting there's there's 22
people in check I would alright 22
people white is victorious let's see if
let's see if everybody paid attention to
what kind of challenges were taken today
hey they sure did alright
adrian 666 like some he got on board he
got on board yeah it's nice to get off
to a good start
yeah yeah right yeah will we see the
color variation yes we got the link
right so now the links are up in both
the chats here pretty fly for a Wi-Fi
says can't miss on my comer stream very
true
they are the best Friday's are what it's
all about oh I miss I missed the win
already but that's alright yeah had some
at some point we'll have to get Danny in
here just for a moment to explain we
there's gonna be a stream tomorrow as I
understand Oh controversial right yeah I
don't I don't know anything about it but
I learned about it today you know we're
adding streams all the time you guys
keep watching us you guys keep following
we'll just keep adding new content so we
got a lot of new stuff coming in okay do
you want to say it on this stream okay
who cares about alpha zero Denis Boros
Jacob Wilkins what time is that 3:00
p.m. and they're gonna talk about the
big match between alpha zero oh yeah
yeah so yeah check it out that's gonna
be awesome
is there another thing is there don't
wanna say too much but the the lady
thing
is that the 31st at 8:00 p.m.
you got officials oh wow
that's gonna be something to watch so
yeah we're adding content all the time
to our twitch channel so stay tuned
all right back to my comer here yeah it
could be some matches yeah a lot of
content could be coming to the twitch
channel monster hunt reunite good to see
you again even watching any Tata Steel
I've been watchin touch a steel I
haven't really been following Gibraltar
very much watching Magnus and in
reasonably good for him
hey Eddie gosh darn it why is that
let's go fast easy way in on time - and
OH - and oh yeah yeah Magnus fishy was a
great game
nobody knows what's going to remove
that got my check going again yeah yeah
yeah he doesn't know how to deal with
the check up upon somehow and now I'm
gonna go there anyway just for fun just
for fun
just for fun all right just for fun oh
yeah who needs that there's Brookes
gonna be gone in a minute here oh it's
just take my night just take it while
you have the chance that's what I would
do
he's gotta move this night and
something's gonna happen bad might
happen here but at least we're up a few
seconds so that counts for something I
want to get casted no there's my work
but that's my that's right as long as
you do it fast right this is real chess
here a minute real chess gosh darnit get
out of here
work yes there you go
they just harass that rook Rasim again
and again hey I told you when that rook
I told you told you and it all came to
be
now this guy doesn't know what he's
doing yeah yeah just give up yeah all
right hopefully they can hear all the
tables moving because it makes this you
know we're real experienced right here
I saw three and I'll see if I can keep
that keep the good times rolling be oh
[Music]
yeah you know honestly if people do have
ideas for what kind of content they'd
like to see on Twitch that maybe doesn't
exist at all you know maybe we can find
something play the people is obviously
great but there's other stuff we can do
so you guys got ideas just throw them
out there if we pretty much do whatever
people want yeah we're here for the
people yeah
don't even wanna throw in that check my
best [ __ ] up
know he could take my pawn he did see
like I make a pace on the hell for this
doesn't look like it I know he was going
back to bishops see what I can do it
first I'll pin the night
there's someone accomplished I should
not be trading it really doesn't just
fast and bad don't get it done check you
go yeah yeah just keep removing
[Music]
undefeated I still undefeated but plus
zero so I did not get the 1800 on that
one
Robo this will take me to 1800 so we
already got the got back to 1800 so so
if you guys were watching last time I
did get to 1800 and I logged up so
somebody must have been playing and not
doing as well as I do yeah well I think
I have ideas for something that was I
was thinking about today for doing blitz
slash rapid games with running
commentary
we do have dgt setup upstairs right now
so we could for example have two people
play a rating game Oh people
I already people are down here doing
commentary for it excellent
you know something like gave me 30
minutes like the staff tournament last
night that uh yeah Caleb Demby won again
he's good he's good yeah so that's a
good idea
so we can do that something like that um
chess not his life is that really
appreciate let's go
more information and tomorrow special
stream what do you want to know what do
you want to know yeah if you guys also
have questions about the alpha0 match
that you guys still want to get in we
can ask Vanessa and mr. Jacob Wilkins
tomorrow so it's gonna be an exciting
event very special they've been wanting
to do it for quite a while just keep
checking right just keep checking in is
that checkmate didn't even know it they
never know but I got the Queen's I got
already got the 1800 so that's really
Dennis through is to bring blam yeah
yeah yeah I knew I just didn't want to
out all they said was very entertaining
it was entertaining was fun watching all
this all those points okay
yes
Now or Never oh don't walk in to oversee
work so he's not taking anything okay
you're not taking anything bishops got
to become better than his cm eCos he
says hey Mike
hello my bishops not doing anything but
now yeah oh yeah there is there is now
it's a please keep munching I love the
King warrior
that King doesn't know what to do now
all right if they see a bronze defense
all things Mike's hairline is blowing my
mind right now
all right the less that one difference
they'll end up hated I was a good one
that was a good one
remember only rated ones only rated ones
and that guy was higher rated than me
too so not bad at all enough a hit hit
off this is probably the guy that's just
guy he's been making lots of comments on
the YouTube lots of comedy and also
interest that he gets to play go to bed
okay does good it doesn't even matter
well take good comments we'll take
comments we love them all we love them
all good to see ya real war P saying he
hates blitz but he guesses the least
it's less computer cheaters votes which
I haven't really noticed has a big
problem on the one now these when we're
streaming but I don't know why it likes
this wasn't my night have anywhere to go
are you only doing one minute games yes
yes yes of course one minute rated is he
gonna checkmate me somehow yeah no oh my
dollars checkmate threats are clinically
he's so mad he can't move that out I can
just feel his face it's like damn what
you're not gonna take my age upon I did
that to goad you I did that to goad pin
it again and it againi Oh
checkmate get out of it okay nonsense
nonsense Oh daddy had made him like to
to it probably yeah no but who cares i
won easy win no I was not easy
hips okay says Mike's too fast for him
oh good yeah I think we have a new Mouse
here so it really does help a lot it
though it doesn't make a difference some
play for like a week and come back it's
a whole new computer all-new Mouse and
it looks very serious oh really oh I did
not notice that's a new computer - yeah
everything's new yeah no wonder on the
oh well I have not lost with this new
setup yeah
all right abort abort what school
runescape you have to challenge again
Paul correct yes opponent says gg ok
and nobody wants to play I might have to
go to the one oh are the Oh No alright
we've come here the first comer
variation now it worked out so well it's
good oh I want to play check so bad but
it's probably bad hey up up easily
caress your just not with the times but
you're not with the times
oh my gosh just move this guy's kind of
making me mad he's trying to move really
fast it's over okay give it okay I got
that not that I need it but hey
everybody can have it okay take it all
okay check me I'm gonna black with my
queen that's how crazy that's crazy I'm
still somehow ahead on time even though
this guy's been playing super fast oh oh
I wonder what your threat is I'm gonna
let you have it okay it's on nice out
man kind of weird sometimes you just got
to be nice okay yeah I'll go get my
queen okay stop it
now you make me mad like that make that
one guy mad
that where's your book big guys move too
fast
but luckily he's really bad that's
alright game Paul grass that thing I
already played that guy alright SS me
ghost who's been in the chat as well
Kimiko someone talking about your
hairline
oh so it's personal no personal it's
blowing his mind right now I guess so I
do need to get a haircut
so should I get a haircut where I just
put my hair down or something is that
what everybody's yelling about cuz I can
do anything I can have any haircut not
spiky enough what's the deal spikey
enough yeah poly that's the reason yeah
undefeated yeah everyone will know how
to make a draw with Mike yeah surprising
the client you could have drawn to Mike
comer yeah run around the town sing I
drew my comer
Oh preparing a big check wasn't worth it
probably yeah this is you know it's a
Sicilian you play rook takes c3 you just
win
all right good right yeah good to see
him Italy below Diego just watching from
Italy good to see ya
what's happening here since the first
time we're getting in trouble I think
I'm fine but who knows I got that check
yeah whatever
hey I did not see that coming did not
see that check coming that's that kind
of made me mad but just take your time
meet ghost take your time and play good
moves go nice and slow
oh he stopped the check that was my own
watching life from Egypt Cara Muhammad
good to see ya very exciting and now
with my comeback right hopefully you got
something here always oh here we go here
we go 13 seconds to 13 seconds you gotta
go fast who's the fastest fast gonna
have all my pawns go fast
I needed that pawn though okay
oh I worked in the Czech no fast fast I
think I messed up the stalemate there
unbelievable all I had to do was go to
c6 and that would have been stalemate
huh yeah you had a free rook - fair
weather man
aspiring Phoenix how did I not know
where to go this person is not a Phoenix
yet but they're aspiring to be one why
there's a big question mark by his name
all right good game Miko's
got everything he wanted this guy odds
upon right who cares how it happens
oh my guess you're not gonna get you're
not gonna get it back yes you've been
doing lots of prep in the Humber
variation is that what's going on I said
how you took him down yeah start
prepping for her yeah I practically I
should have drawn them that was a big
mistake on my part
good to see you RV yes we are reading
the live chats
don't even think about it I know exactly
what move this kiss I got a rip and
thing and game how can I get it can I
just get it yeah now you have to put
your rook there and oh you want to go
there abundant alright got the dumb rook
I love that I love it
Sean hot stone this rook really is all
right now is your chance to take it if
you want it all right here he'll do it
for that pawn but not the other point
yeah all right it's all gonna come down
to the final seconds too early to give
up your rook way too early
yes bearing Phoenix really mopping
through everybody today I'm on a mission
I'm gonna miss I don't know what the
mission is but I'm on up yeah well below
1800 on orth the game you're too slow
buddy too slow you gotta be fast you
wanna play one minute you gotta be fast
except John Boaz Boaz a good spirit
call me Bob oh he took the long way oh
and then he didn't take it all oh my
gosh
Commission is the road to 2000 I guess
that's okay we're over 2000 well that
helps
that's the fence yeah we've got to start
playing people that are a little bit
gallagher watching from mexico good to
have you
hello oh yeah the calorie kortner we
love it we love the Caledon court yep
we're only doing bullet one oh right in
this isn't that good talent in court I
messed up the move orders and it's a
disaster
look at my bishops they're gonna become
monsters so somehow someway yeah I knew
he wanted that so bad
I hope you should check was silly yeah
we'll play anyone as long as this one
minute
yeah one of the people their mouse
wasn't working when they you accepted
their challenge
not my problem oh we got the we got the
good mouse is this oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa
tell me came in oh wow what a move and
it got rid of his bishop well not quite
but working on it you know what night
for a rook throw it or move faster I'm
tempted I was tempted straighten up all
my pawns but I guess it worked out
better
come on get my king out of here and
let's go let's go oh wait they snuck in
he snuck in that come from where I think
yeah I mean I hate the call you might
exceed by accusing people of cheating
but that looked very suspicious you
can't just all of a sudden like Oh Benny
yeah and then as night comes into for
the win I mean you're faster than
everybody in the world go slowly
catching you're slowly catching oh and I
was two away from stalemate again I go
here yeah he pushes I go there stealth
if again Luke answered in the chat good
to see ya I'm gonna take all my paint on
this guy Oh what most isn't working Oh
interesting what every move
okay hey has a chance to take it in blue
I know it's the original Sean's here
another Shantz is kind of you know he
was bringing a little bit of dishonor to
our family I had to come back and
although it's funny the other day it was
Perry on the stream but everybody
thought it was Isaac's everyone's
everyone's thinking that's my brother my
world to be my younger brother lots of
time for everybody no reason why it
should mess this up especially what
moves like that absolutely ridiculous
for way to mess this one up probably is
checkmate you know even I saw the
checkmate that's when that's when you
know it's bad bad chess player thank you
we're interested okay yeah someone was
asking if you're only playing people
under eighteen hundred we're not getting
many challenges of the other one way so
yeah I guess people can't see it on the
screen when you're selecting them but
yeah it's mostly under eighteen hundreds
we just play whatever challenges us oh
is it was a trick it was a trick he's
got it protections I thought that was
winning no this guy's playing so fast -
supposed to be bad this wasn't fun
anymore sorry let's go
I got a lot of stuff going on he should
have played there but he didn't all
right yeah what are your favourite
openings it seems like comer variation
Sicilians popular calendars court will
seem to me of my classics so if you're
doing lots of mic prep those little ones
you want to book up on that night
singing oh yeah DD John oh good to see
ya yeah I still play my king higher you
got this all favored still lots of time
no reason for white to mess this up
Andy's playing so fast to come has an
excellent understanding for his rating
yeah mhm
whatever I'll straighten up your pawns
for you this is my chance
oh good one bad chess player so this is
probably their first game of bullet
actually you can look see what their
real rating is if you hover over them
they've never played bullet before that
could really be something good strong
player 1800 little women okay where is
the highest rated player in the queue
18:39 Luke hazard Luke Luke before I'll
play like Denis balls
it was fun having Denese in here he'd
played d3 make it look like it's the
most aggressive opening you've ever seen
there you go
I had a feeling that was coming at this
point got to do it inside and you know
oh I'd better not get checked like like
that
I always trying to he's trying the firm
I guess oh please take it please take it
please Victor we're doing one Oh today
so anything else will probably be
rejected I didn't fall for your little
trap in there you don't know what the to
get all my pieces are so far up there
we've got a passer that's all that
matters I got two passes the two
pitchers yeah you should take my knight
at once
we go this is the time
up on time might get back rope
checkmater those Willis just stop that
makes it look to get another passer I
could have taken this rook you didn't
see that check comes ready
no I ready for your too many rooks to
merit so the highest rate of guy that's
that's why the the higher rated people
don't challenge me okay because they
know I'm gonna take all their points all
their points okay right and we want to
we want them back as long as we end up
over 1800 again it's alright Oh Luke
wasn't ready when you hit start
they never they're never ready they're
mice don't work the mouse's they're
never ready always at the bathroom when
you start the game so one minute game
you gotta be ready
I got some ideas I guess some ideas ever
ready for the mic Ness monster oh this
guy is just a little while
oh are you caffeinated enough for
today's no no no we have a we have a
what do we need to do here we gonna
probably yeah
leave the lowest-rated now play Louis
waiter says the 900
well where are you going with that I
don't like that and I do not like that
that's night out of here
oh look it's your H pawn oh he sawed
open it and it yeah I think he playing
fast or doing a long time a long time I
think I'm in our dating I think I'm
gonna mating that here God has made his
King a warrior
I like this guy was a great move yes
that was a great move that was a great
one move of the day move of the day
playing on leeches well five five points
away from the 1800 right where we random
champ gamer what an excellent username
new wrinkle there we go yeah that's sick
of everybody taking on c6 oh come on
please take it please take it please
take it yeah right have you do it you do
it you know you know wow what a thinker
what a thinker this kid is oh I'm pinned
no wonder he thought so long on that
boom it was a good one it was a good one
it was a don't play so well please
thanks for the game Mike you guys are
awesome keep spreading this awesome game
thanks for your lessons - on YouTube
meaning the life revealed doesn't get
much better than that is Jonathan
playing today nope I'll be playing on
Tuesdays at noon central time saying
kind of see our dream schedule there I
got the Tuesday shift Wednesday has been
Ryan or somebody else I'm gonna do the
ones Thursday's it's the GM stream and
Fridays just wrap off the week Mike come
here there's no other way I'd ever miss
my week there without a mic Commerce
stream
why do people prefer Lee chest over
chest calm just calm is so much better I
guess I'll show that for some reason
that got hidden but uh yeah we know we
kind of know the people they're just
that common they're all so good we're
just doing this cuz you know they puts a
little thing I don't know if I'm just a
comment puts you like on a little thing
telling everybody to come and watch this
maybe sometimes we'll switch over but
this is what we're running with it seems
to be working for us
one time if we can hold yes plus nine
back over the 1800 mark all right yes
people are hoping you increase your
reading so they can play you in the
tickle your points
oh so that's that's how it is if people
don't wanna play you till you get your
eating up hate you back down now we see
how it goes
Thank You mr. Irsay priyanka for the
kind words
DJ Jen oh he's gotten in the chest here
and a half go and mics videos have been
helping him out oh good excellent now
hopefully uh hopefully once you get good
like that you can just move on to
somebody else and forget everything I
taught you
so that's it alright yeah it's too good
it's too good rush them yeah I mean the
opening I just play the opening like a
master you know
all right who's any good here anybody
any good I think I already could see you
Mike you're a true inspiration I think I
already never given to the haters to say
see em is out of reach that's probably
the peak of your potential see em that's
the ceiling USCF see em right rising
penguin where is Isaac probably asleep
it's only like three forty four in the
afternoon probably sounds like a pro
gamer uh-oh he almost snuck one through
me 300 Wow nice try
yeah if you're fast enough yeah [ __ ]
you might as well just taste mine gold
variation no it's not the fine gold very
that was your thing but it's it's it was
different if we're not yeah yeah it's
not the right we do some three
mini-games no oh hey what you just
watching is a subscriber though Wow he's
like a twitch subscriber
sometimes you should makes exceptions
well Victor Tim he's for wanting o
against st. Louis that's very upsetting
to us God I want to take it so wait so I
played g5 right and I probably [ __ ]
throughout no G pipes
she [ __ ] always does right yeah II
think you're so cool second a bishop for
a well whatever it's like it's the
points pretty much all equal out so well
now he pins me whatever you want me to
take that pawn so bed you've got okay oh
now you got with the twenty five bits
thank you very much bushed
too many pieces for this guy
but he's getting closer to me I will
give him that you're getting closer
whatever keep up to speed here keep up
just being you got to sometime for sure
John Mike make it up 12 the way over
1800 now way over 1800 the road the two
thousand all right almost it is Mike
Jeff experienced slumps and you're
playing where you can't seem to win a
game for a few days or even a week have
you been watching the stream the hope
maybe if maybe a l-3 losing streak but
then you just find somebody that you can
then you know you compete and drinks
over okay yep dee takes c6
Quintus you have to play Quintus I'm
2100 I can easily obliterate you you're
next that you're at your if you're in
the queue I'll play you okay not you
is that your handle quinn test however
the 2100 is that's what we're playing do
we also have tilts and just like poker
yeah absolutely
which one of you is Atanas coleauxv
neither it's got it there on the screen
this is what happens when Isaac's not
here I think I think Isaac's the
graphics guy well we got someone coming
in Oh a secret person you know hopefully
it's a coffee runner right yeah let's
get let's get that going let's get there
Danny get someone on the coffee runs
let's go there should be automatic win
huh automatic win cuz I got this
checking friends for sure alright
alright here we go here we go here we go
how do we bring this home just keeping
up the banter oh my god difference in
ratings should be enough to see now this
guy's in my head - he says he'll be
playing in the courts tonight
always will see you honey alright the
Battle of his two pawns I guess my two
pawns who's better
it looks like my pawns are better way
better
it's actually sort of a woman thing
where they can never actually write you
can't eat it you can't eat it
yeah you can't do this can't eat all
right where's this let's check that out
yes for sure talking a lot of trash yeah
just go like yeah I do the wheel the
wheel
cuz I've got to see what being drunk
lifeguards on there three or three
people wondered where Isaac is he's
right there joining us to the wrong
thing
there's no 21 hundreds on yeah yeah oh
I'll play I'll play
Isaac's Ron since everybody's been
talking about I'm on the stream what's
wrong Quintus too scared to play my
comment thought you were 2100 all right
here's the real battle this is what
we're here for
1% see if he knows that yeah anytime you
can all pass on always on Poisson
that's the rule and when you when you're
not castling he's castle break open the
center okay got it yeah
oh he's mocking me smacking me but
that's very oh wow we won for it
there's no way this is good you know
maybe in a 1 minute game that would be
good but and I'm just gonna eat this
pawn - don't
man if I play there he's gonna play
there I bet what's the time at your
place it's 350 350 huh here in central
time in Missouri yeah this one's not
bullet but this is a drunk lifeguard
that's Isaac's runts my brother not
Perry Coulson when is Isaac on the
stream
they're always losing I think you're
actually wrong rising penguin because it
was there was a stream where it said
Isaac but it was Perry the whole time so
a lot of people are a little bit
confused
Isaac is younger than me when you're up
trade right I think it's what they say
that's what they say you don't get
checkmate in here no he's coming in for
a check he's coming in for a check to do
them for like preemptively I'll just
pretend like I was checked don't give
him a satisfaction don't give him the
satisfaction
published I can't push the pun they're
just hanging out in the corner okay oh
my gosh oh oh it's oh it's like Oh
everything's just falling apart and this
is like a three minute game how am i
right you got to slow down that's
actually a good trick on Isaac's part
you switch over to three hours you're
not you know into that mode gonna play
too fast but actually I think I think
Queen to e7 was actually the best move
in that position I think it's a chess
beserker anyone in lose to anyone all
right let's be careful in the chat about
you guys can make fun of me and Mike but
let's try not to make fun of our other
people watching in the chat I saw you a
little trick I saw your little check
somehow see anyway we're all trained oh
I got oh man oh man would you miss I
don't want to talk about it with you but
let's not it might have this game could
be over right now we do it 3 2 now for
Isaac will play a the 3-minute game but
then we got to get back to the 101
overrated this is just ridiculous
I could've had checkmate on you Isaac
and you didn't even know how you don't
even know how he knew it never worked
no I was gonna checkmate him on g3 you
saw it yeah so all I had to do was play
Queen 2 there he would have played this
little bishop move and they would have
been over all right hopefully I got
checkmate here somehow
there's no it's gonna be tricks with
taking his knight in back Cranky's that
he'll never see look for those as well
right what time should I challenge 101
Oh rated Oh Oh but luckily my bishops
word should be well calculated sir
alright this is just gonna be mob you
can have my bishop I'm a nice guy I
guess yes all right
much sizing for the game Thank You Isaac
all right back to one oh yeah I might
already play this Batman Begins but I
was not a fan of the movie so I will
play oh wow I'm out of the mode now I'm
out of the mode it's like it's tough to
get back in that mode it was a great
time to challenge us with some women and
games
but somehow I'm winning well I guess I'm
higher rated than you Batman Begins I'm
higher rated than you that means I'm
better than you so much I guess I'll
take it thanks for telling me I'm a
check I helped
we wanted just oh that's oh well this is
the best move this is the best
all right let's let's not let's not joke
around here these two pawns are better
than my guys let's not get bankrupt
checkmated that's first things first and
now do I have this trick thank you oh
wait well I did not get backwards
checkmated let's just take it like Han
and now let's try to take babies you're
definitely playing five rating points
better than this guy
yeah it really shows that's the big
difference between 1812 and 1817 it's
trying to do something here oh my gosh
and I gotta get checkmate in here well
then all right yep that's a good one
that was it go Batman Begins thank you
for the points yeah yeah if you watch
that meaning a life revealed we have a
big thing about Batman in there that's a
good rating but one oh please a bad
chess player I borrowed him all the way
up to 21:59 gonna take him back down
this probably after one game right right
it's like I give you a little pointer
but I don't that's a trick that's our
send-off I'm gonna play efore against
them see what he can do but we actually
have no idea it looks like this person's
played one game on this account like a
bishop go this is the book house that's
a knight
what are you doing trust me you're the
beat a bad chess player you have to play
like a player that's the trick
I'm stop calling me I know
work but please other check
yeah sorry Patrick
does he have any kind of checkmate
threat but he just yeah he just lost
this Queen right oh stop I wish I could
play King
oh don't move seem like a dumb move
that doesn't work do I have anything
don't move your neck
oh you move you're not I'm just yeah you
play bad just playin okay so bad yeah
like it's too good
wait what's their rating now ways to 100
guys power maybe that's you in a minute
if you're like 2,400 crazy maybe you
don't give all your pieces away at the
beginning I guys so play before me but
yet again I played them already
yeah Bob all right well plan one more
time
well nope too slow
oh yeah who opened that one the door and
then coffee didn't come in yeah I'm not
worried I'm sure Danny's on it yeah it
looks like he's all over it
here we go here that worked again
yeah the summoning seems to win quickly
on occasion so now he's yeah yeah just
give them a thank you yeah I didn't want
to think which one I wanted to take all
right good nobody Oh a once they once a
once alright I was like once they won oh
yeah he doesn't strike me as a window
player so I think Mike is the big
favorite in this matchup and it's uh
where's Mike overextended as Isaac
gracefully hops his knights around guy
with the beard what is your name my name
is Jonathan also known as and friends
Wow we got you got lucky you got dang it
all of a sudden out of nowhere what's
happening straight it's just a kid Hong
with the show some of this is working as
Caleb Denby oh you the coffee guy Danny
Machuca guy what are you doing what are
you fixing a camera no they can see you
famous streamer
oh I was bad of me it was so bad
I beat Isaac Isaac away over 1800 now
and we started under 7 or under 1800
because of a Dennis LaRue was the
culprit I got you all the way up to 1800
and now now I'm on the road to mm yeah
because I've been going to a Caleb's
class Wednesdays at 6
absolutely yeah and that's why that's
why I'm on the road and I'm finally on
the road yeah there's an episode that's
actually gonna premiere on our YouTube
channel so Clark so what we got about a
half-hour to get to a 1,900 maybe I was
just stopping by all right could you
help me out look so much I don't know
what to do for Mike because there's an
extra drink coffee what do you need you
need I need to get the 1980 s
through on each six nope that was fun oh
that's supposed to be checking me that's
not how it works
that's a drama here let's just get rid
of this pole all right you're the best
all right thank you very well thanks go
yeah
Caleb's been around for a lot of the
streams too so very cool
all right I think I've got this thing in
the bag now come in yeah we are alive
today oh yeah I mean you guys can't just
walk in because it's you know it's too
extreme they sure seen everyone Raymond
is saying hi Beth famous I think that's
I barely know the rules hopefully is in
here challenging us let's good this guy
check finally nice to spare I needed
that pun I needed that push take that
pawn and take on up to and yeah said I
would a queen and you're right yeah like
how are you gonna check make me even get
that Queen and take at least five moves
21 challenges Judy's racking him up
there all what would you say and then
the one guy you know the rules just
joined not that one he's casual Oh
casual come on you had your chance
Freeman let's clean up some of these
challenges hey Saturn berry and lamb
came lots of names I don't recognize
good to see you guys
alright here we go I would put that I
don't think we played this guy yet
I am 17 it appears there want to know
against this alright gotta well who
knows if that's us are yeah we can go
for the draw again alright he doesn't
want it I couldn't tell if you were
trying to play a six or a five a five
obviously sure now you want them oh
that's fine I can't even take that night
oh yes I could
and on the why you wanted to trade
Queens oh now it now go on your big
attack yeah you know yeah great idea
well I'm not I'll take the triple pawns
I just want to see how their power let's
do let's see where it goes one oh and I
can't let you have nothing why look at
this move their way out of one of my
triple pawns at least just take it
please hey I'll pay you to take a triple
pulling detect them okay Oh what now I
can take it I'm looking good I'm looking
good I'm looking good I'm Way better at
this guy in Knight end games - so it's
actually your specialty which is that
joke so senior say most recent game well
I guess the rest is arrested crush the
wrench at the night in game oh where are
you going
but he's distracted now I know yes your
skills are tremendous push your pawns oh
he got me
almost that was not a good one
I am 17 stop beating us here right he's
in our heads he's that hurts bro key boy
Dallin that one heart that one heart you
know really came down to the where no
you get this every single game it should
have never taken those triple pawns it's
it yeah it's not cool to just mess
around during the game she got to be you
got to play good the whole time no none
of this mess around anymore
no way without any way it worked out
anyway I won his queen it all worked out
in the end it all worked out in the end
not afraid of no discovered shook just
munch munch munch put somebody in a pen
and come on let's just play already
can we play play always stop worked
interesting
it's this is the time to resign right
agreed but now I got now I got the rook
for the checkmate I deserved that two
points yes
all right now we got a real challenge
here we are now I hasn't played a move
yet he hasn't played a move yet maybe's
Mouse is broken this a casual I got Mike
let's go okay interesting starts this
guy's good you can't just okay I'm not
Kings a warrior remember well alleged I
want my rook
not the recommended way to beat a 2400
yeah we'll see how it works out he's got
him thinking oh I guess he thinks he's
has like made a well I've calculated Oh
Mary don't know thirteen good Black is
notorious what happened there yeah what
king was too strong Mike King was too
strong immortal that's a game for the
ages beat a senior master he knew my
King was just gonna March up and eat the
brook and there was nothing I could do
about it
oh here we go let's go let's get a chest
expert going here let's play you for see
if he's silly naughty hater GM ain't
gonna put GM next to their name it's so
scary they work out the King in the
center King
crushing this guy too
you can have the bishop pair I'm sure
you know how to use them hey new Devils
what's happening here we're winning
obviously those pawns again I'm a double
pawns can this guy have
I'm never gonna undo one for you that's
not how I do it
new Devils must be someone we know
they're saying
see you tonight Mike cope can't wait
should be a fun one I would do anything
for this pawn yeah that was a silly move
that was a silly move this Preston would
say no silly chess expert once you're
beat on easily right by nobody cares
about that F pawn Wow
oh it was almost good well it cost them
a second or two on the clock that's for
sure no I got it another pass now I'm
not in the windmill I'm not in the
windmill you better hurry up
geez I'm crushing this fool good yeah
you might as well just take it oh I
can't look well I can lose right they
don't have that rule huh draw is it good
good good result all right yeah I don't
like how they had that rule where up
like if they have a lone Bishop it's a
win for them right if I were a rules
alright so that that's that's why I
freaked out at the
oh I bet I hate I don't like that I
don't like that guy
first they're asking you to play again
they've even made it rain at this time
like best Scotch 1860 wow I'm I really
am only 40 points away but I got to go
to the break though I gotta go to the
bank Brett what do you need to go to the
bank this is the opening why don't you
like me I like you because I barely know
the rules fight cause you beat me all
the time alright stop beating me Oh
today are your intentions to wrap this
up in 15 minutes you got places to be
I got to go to the bank but I do want to
get to 1900 it depends how close I am to
1900 maybe I don't know what to see but
yeah I always play give us a warning
when there's like one or two left okay
don't let me get Danny back in here
anyway Danny and Danny oh yeah we I mean
Caleb had a stall big time last last
week because Dean has really know the
rules we'll let you in if you play not
rated not interested it was alright
though I have checkmate here I'll be
like that guys calculate now is all that
smart little smart oh my gosh no matter
what oh wow is it yes plus one that was
a very maybe scotch Chivas oh the
valiant effort you tried to play like me
get this King way up there and see what
happens
gotta know what you do and when that
happens I don't know what you do a
chance we need to get the reading points
this is the game that's not good move
all right I'm winning game they have two
missions really happy there goes one
Bishop there goes one Bishop oh stop it
yeah been fangled feels are very funny
yeah he thinks he's so good but the
truth comes out the truth comes out
about this guy the truth comes out and
comes the truth get to know the truth
I'm not that bad right watching this now
I can play it oh my god is your boy back
I don't need that [ __ ] yeah yeah he
wants my pawns maybe I want you to have
my pawns did you ever think about that
I gotta get my work playing on Oh
discovered Chuck really blew that
discovery check
meaning you do I have any stop the mate
somehow I gotta set up the meet somehow
good Stephanie it's always possible but
checkmate seems more likely yeah well no
not checkmating you go the other way
oh I said never given up all right well
played you play better than us I guess
you went help it every hitter we meet
again oh really that's the draw he had
cuz you you could have flagged them
beaten oh man
that's so nice this time just playing
[Music]
it's probably a bit like the sofas
position
mmm-hmm kind of scared kind of scared
huh Wow come on fight so close so close
so close comeback kid here oh come on
let's do something is it where's the
discovery I don't think I have one
shucks
that doesn't mean I have to oh my god I
blew it and I thought too long and I
just blew it are the rook in there and
life will be good huh I got some chances
still got some chances
we are STL in Missouri st. Louis
Missouri
need that night I need that night oh oh
and a dull before like what could have
gone wrong like a triple blunder usually
city double blunders but now you got to
see a triple blunder I shouldn't kept
that poem I went against mine I showed
him mercy that maybe they'll show me
mercy you never know well then the big
Brooke second that seal the deal we just
need to hold on to the center Barry come
by the club 1,800 by the end of the
stream hate it the way it's looking that
Oh like high school chess where I lose
sort of seems like it Oh worse tech
nothing yes not good
all right thank you that really helped
especially if I could have checkmate
right now well take what we can get
we'll take what we can
oh this guy's falling apart oh man do I
want it let's just deal it's we can
trade later yeah you didn't expect me to
tackle this game just take a pause see
that one coming I know I get the bishop
oh I should still lose oh so I guess you
better take that night all right I
better get this I better get this guy a
big win polyester HS great to see Mike
it's great to see you
I walk it looks like you gotta figured
out yeah he knows how to make with a
queen and a king can you believe it
that's 12 points all right let's see if
we can get the 1900 somehow something
else
oh that now I'm not playing you again no
no never again you're too good stop
beating us we need to play somebody
though that we can get some points magic
okay I don't know if we played I don't
know if we played this guy over it's
like we won we won okay good it down
there so yeah oh I got you yeah people
talking about the 90th percentile that's
not as good as you think like 90th
percentile
it doesn't want to fork me fine oh that
was a big mistake you know what you can
have my work I don't once I work I'm
chewing on that date anyway I gotta win
we gotta win
all right okay be kind
good to see ya
oh there you go checkmate - no I got
this magic guy keep playing magic yeah
all right we'll get for that ten points
rate at half +0 fastest because 1555 if
you lose twenty eight points
twenty-eight points to go huh that could
be just one big win huh one big win
that's true but that's not gonna happen
we need about three or four medium ones
well here's one don't mess this up Oh
case Mike I like my chances
yeah Miko's you've gotta lose to us
though if we play you can't be beating
us we're trying to get to 1900
interesting
I'm up a piece so what am I freaking out
take it I don't even know if I wanna
write all your pieces to makovski no he
knew it right where I was going
I had that one I knew I was there I
should help remove that yes that was
easy how was the wait is that plus four
I need a little more than forward yeah
yeah we got to play the 17 1800 s
marathon miles I mean that's I'm better
than him I better think you won last
time we played so I couldn't remember
what what there was always I've got a
higher rating then I'm better than him
right lazy he's scared
okay here we go we played this doesn't
see our buzzer yes I never believed it
or not I never know the way the way you
don't wait don't shoulda done it
Michael's gonna wonder if you know how
oh yeah right oh no all right two for
one
let's do it oh my gosh oh my gosh hey
they want it he's too smart ministers
how are you um well I got a piece out of
it that's right if you think in this
game you're dead
you're done all right yeah yeah this
would get me close guys go he got from
18 I've got nine 34 right or just take
it or just take oh and then check and
all that stuff this is funny here yeah
take the work on it if you insist if you
insist
yeah no no I was great everybody can
understand remove the check mate why
don't we have a 40 no air with a real
drag oh okay got another 18 that's what
we need that's what we need Wardley no
way we can just wins in a row good good
thank you for taking that
check that was Jack yeah pieces don't
matter pieces don't matter now I'm as
outraged he's over just don't remove
that know that
all right fine you had all your chances
to take that pawn now you got another
chance I guess Oh
another bad way that stalemate it is
they'll make sure this oh I meant to
play h5 that way all right
top setback only 29 points that's easy
does anything what's up hello and
welcome to Treach yeah so we're on the
internet right now yeah if you come in
you don't have to be on the camera but
you can check out the TV if you'd want
to see it because yes we can see
everything on this TV and then he's
playing chess against people on the
internet and doing very well doing all
right
free Brooke free Brooke so now he's
crushing people we're playing one minute
games
you got to play well so the people yeah
right too much pressure too much
pressure there you go now you're getting
it back together now you're getting
yourself back together here
now we right good to see you w Bennett
that's good to have you with us very
active on all of our YouTube comments
like I got this like my keys
I don't think there's anything you can
even do do this yes big win
plus a 1 yeah that's for not in front of
a crowd too in front of a live studio
audience
all right well I don't know if we're
gonna be able to make it how many more
you got in you maybe we got a maybe we
just got to create a gank oh all right
yes do it the old-fashioned way 17
second he's got 17 seconds to play the
first move
this guy's too good
is he is he have a high rating 1795 well
he's much better than the 1795 sorry pen
please play the people that played this
all right fine you want it really it
doesn't want it distract them
I had a distracted you I distracted you
I'm so distracted
who would play them fine I got all that
you wanted I know why you don't want it
I'll take a little tripled not that
that's doing anything Wow occasionally
your moves surprise me but it helped it
helps get help to positions much better
now that was good too
[Music]
distraction that was he never saw that
one coming 54 moves we played and most
of them great alright alright we have
anybody in this thing quick pawns or
this guy so this we can just retire
after this one played before anybody
okay what you're worried about
can always check
no he he felt so good when he played
that movie felt so good Queen takes
Queen everybody saw it everybody's not
nobody cared don't always setting up a
big trick I might be a little bit better
than me just a little bit it's just all
right there we go comeback is on they
come back is oh oh this guy is freaking
out oh it's no way I can stop that huh
I'm close to might not sit
come on come on come on do it might find
the mate yes I found the mate
oh my guess I found the mate
what why all right now we're back in it
now we're back in it look at that how
did we only get seven for that I thought
we were I would thought I was playing a
master alright so what do we need we
need like six or something about yoni
for I don't want to play you probably
only need to play like 15 yeah another
whoa whoa you can play like all I need
is a draw right Colleen is a drill Wow
are you playing a true professional here
thank you nice try nice try
Wow I like my chances here I like my
chances I like my charity so let's can I
just corral it all I need is a draw
right
sorry we're disappointing you pro wing
it's not interesting you know the guy
find a checkmate with 0.6 seconds oh my
gosh alright I guess
all right we still love you too bro wing
I guess with you mess around a little
bit too much share come on he's waiting
till the last second
he's trying to flag you up like a
thousand seconds
big time show off saying I'm faster than
you I could pre move faster come on Mike
you got the Magic Mike let's do it oh
you don't want to stay I want to stop no
it's distracted him if he's gonna flag
me do a little dance do a little dance
maybe I needed those two seconds huh
yeah maybe I should have taken that
pause we lost two points this there we
go oh I know I know I know
all right Joe slime bringing us back to
the comment that started the whole thing
off what is my covers haircut called
asking for a friend
like calmer obviously just going then
it's like give me the comer
it's tough to get this last six points
is good but you know if you want to be
nineteen hundred sometimes you gotta
beat me ghosts we played kids yep I
think if we played kids we might not
play very close come on yeah hopefully
we get to 1899 and then just call it a
day yeah I'm falling apart this is not
this is not good good
and the same thing is we've never had as
many viewers as now he worships way up
the people aren't talking in the chat so
come on yes Oh and now to do my thing I
don't think it's checkmate though a
little check and then check well played
as well played no just check again like
that
no now I'm stuck oh good I knew he was
gonna play that move we'll find a night
with come are playing bullet does it get
any better than this
not really is this a chess game yeah
it's something similar to just you guys
require playing one oh I'm hopefully
wrapping this up if we get to 1900 here
it's not good oh I need to play Bishop
to g5 here something
can we just check mate this guy already
of it how hard is it oh my god he fell
apart at the end he fell apart yes and
so 1899 I don't think I have one more in
me real any fat sir
just a little tiny baby fish you just
please no any baby oh and sorry somebody
just came in with an 8 1000 let them
before we can give it another go
wrap it up oh my gosh it would just be
too embarrassed because really really
that we kid about it then we can enter
into an 1899 under you 8 1900 tournament
Leanne right that's the one well this
give me a point be the pressure the
pressure is too much no we want to know
when alone but now he's prepared tell us
game
Mosu well I'm not well I might lose but
yes this is the last game for everybody
in there Mike's got to go to the bank no
oh god I do got a car the bank
oh my guess he's got this one trick I
mess with just can't get over it so sick
of that one trick but you got this I
must take this bishop we have been here
oh this dream took down 2,400 there's
some really good people played like a
200 move game against some good person
yeah good stuff happened to finish with
win
no matter how it happens have six of six
people left six go to live six oh no are
you kidding me right now found it they
got ten seconds and they're scared
they've never been beating my cover
before it all right I'm coming back I'm
coming back I think I do
[Music]
that'll be one point all right oh no he
was here but they see how hard it was
for me to win that game you got another
one in you Danny hasn't come in yet so
and even ended anyway to play someone
good but maybe maybe that's what you
gotta do when I lose you know believe we
got zero points
the depressing list to be honest but
Miko's really wants me because no I
really want to earn 1,900 you can give
them a go but I don't really feel like
we want to earn it I think we just want
it just not taking any of them that
could be the one yeah you know the only
one let me come on you're better than
that guy you can win Victor Victor 1500
you can't be a 1900 you know come on
Victor the game now you had your chance
Victor you had your chance
alright we're on our last game here well
not really it's over Danny's coming in
to shut it down eighty ninety nine so
the next show we can go all the way from
eighteen something to 2,000 something
yeah we're on the road to 2,000 we're
not on the road to 1,900 got it
alright well thank you guys everybody
for watching catch the thing tomorrow
the alpha zero you're gonna want to see
that one and there should be a lot of
stuff coming so stay tuned what have a
good night